Despite the observance of the cease-fire today, January 6,
from 12 o'clock Moscow time, the
regime's Russian army group
continued its artillery shelling of
populated areas and positions of Russian
troops in the direction of the
armed forces of Ukraine.
three
artillery shells from the area of ​​the
settlement of Nova Pavlovka,
Zaporozhye region, 8
artillery shells were fired by the return fire of the
Russian troops, the position of the
Armed Forces of Ukraine, from which the
shelling dried up, suppressed,
we know that he can never be trusted,
because they are insidious enemies, and we never
believe, oh, you hear yourself, see  what kind of
truce do they want when
they shoot so that we already know
with our hands that they do not need to believe today the
situation is the same as yesterday the
day before yesterday A week ago a month ago
practically nothing changes
despite the fact that against  nyk if he
announced an armistice
because of the fact that there will be a holiday, but everyone perfectly
understands the special military that it was not
and will not be and to expect from the enemy of
some kind
it has already been proven for years starting from the
14th year that there is nothing to talk about with them
and believe their  promises and
some kind of order by decree make no sense
after the 12th, as you yourself heard,
nothing has changed at all, how were the
shellings, they are
not just that they wanted it to be quieter to lead
you here, we believed it, but they are
deceiving since the 14th year, there were constant
cease-fires, constant cease-fires  the shelling is
felt because the
family is mentioned, the previous years are mentioned, which here
always celebrated these holidays at home in the
family circle, you can't here Well, I
want to go home a little bit, but you still need to
drive them out of our land, then you can
celebrate
me very much here
Yosyp is an old man, once a child  probably
not as boring as all the years ago
, but still it is not a joyful plan for
our country because every family,
unfortunately, did not know which Foxtrot would  Agato,
my brother is fighting now and it's a
little sad that Christmas the
family is going to gather this opportunity
together, we're all gone now, but still
with Vera the meeting of Christmas In short
So my son is performing today In the
theater apartment he is performing today
I expect that Jesus was born in  to the hearts of
each of us, each of us
And
you know, for each of us it depends on
how long he will settle in our hearts
[music]